YACHTS ARE PROBABLY OUT OF REACH
AT THIS STAGE.
>>> RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS WILL
TEST ITS UNITY WHEN IT COMES TO
STANDING UP TO MOSCOW.
EUROPE GETS 45% OF ITS NATURAL
GAS FROM RUSSIA.
HUNGARY, SLOVAKIA, AUSTRIA, AND
GERMANY ARE AMONGST THE MOST
ENERGY DEPENDENT.
THE UNION'S BEEN LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVE SOURCES OF OIL AND
GAS AND THE POTENTIAL INCLUDES
ALGERIA, TURKMENISTAN.
THE EU COMMISSIONER FOR ENERGY,
I'M GRATEFUL THE COMMISSIONER'S
JOINING US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU, MA'AM.
LET'S -- THE -- I SAW YOUR
SPEECH TODAY ABOUT GEOTHERMALS
AND I'VE SEEN YOUR COMMENTS.
THE REALITY IS, IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE EASY, AS THE COMMISSION
PRESIDENT HAS SAID, TO WEAN
EUROPE OFF OIL AND GAS IN SHORT
ORDER.
INDEED, BUT FOR EUROPE, THIS IS
A TURNING POINT.
THIS IS A STRONG CONSENSUS THEY
MUST END OUR DEPEND ON RUSSIA AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT IT IS VERY
CHALLENGING, BUT IT IS DOABLE,
AND AS YOU MENTIONED, MORE THAN
40% OF OUR GAS COMES FROM
RUSSIA.
THIS IS ABOUT 155 BILLION CUBIC
METERS A YEAR, AND MOST OF THIS
IS BY -- IT CANNOT BE REPLACED
OVER NIGHT.
BUT WE BELIEVE WE CAN
INCREASE -- BY AROUND 50 PCM
ANNUALLY, AND IN FACT, LNG
DELIVERS HAVE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY, PARTICULARLY FROM
THE UNITED STATES.
SO THIS HAS HELPED US THIS
WINTER, AND WE DO HAVE ALSO GOOD
CONTACTS WITH OTHER RELIABLE
PARTNERS.
WE DO HAVE PIPELINE --
>> RIGHT, BUT -- IT LOOKS AND
PERHAPS IT IS SELF-SERVING
WITHIN EUROPE NOT TO SANCTION
THE ONE THING THAT WOULD HAVE
DEPRIVED RUSSIA OF MOST OF ITS
REVENUE, WHICH IS OIL AND GAS.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN A PRICE TO BE PAID BY
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES, PARTICULARLY
GERMANY, BUT IT LOOKS
SELF-SERVING THAT THOSE
COUNTRIES WEREN'T PREPARED TO DO
IT.
>> WELL, WE JUST UPDATED THE
FULL PACKAGE OF SANCTIONS SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE WAR, AND
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN A RESPONSE
ON THIS SCALE BY EUROPEAN UNION
AND IN SUCH CLOSE COORDINATION
WITH OUR ALLIES, AND THESE
SANCTIONS ARE ACTUALLY WORKING,
SO WE SEE THE EFFECT ON THE
RUSSIAN ECONOMY ALREADY.
THE STOCK MARKET IS CLOSED AND
RUBLE HAS LOST HALF ITS VALUE
AND COMPANIES ARE FLEEING.
WE HAVE ALSO BANNED ANY
INVESTMENT IN THE RUSSIAN ENERGY
SECTOR, SO WHAT WE ARE DOING IN
PARALLEL IS REDUCING THE AMOUNT
OF RUSSIAN ENERGY WE CONSUME.
SO WE CANNOT STOP USING IT
OVERNIGHT, BUT WE CAN MAKE THIS
PROGRESS VERY FAST, AND WE ARE
DETERMINED TO DO THAT.
>> IS NUCLEAR POWER PART OF YOUR
GRAND PLAN TO WEAN OFF RUSSIAN
OIL AND GAS?
AND INDEED FOR THE ENERGY
TRANSITION?
I AGREE, NICE TO HAVE WIND,
SOLAR, GEOTHERMAL.
ALL OF THESE WILL PLAY A PART.
I'LL GIVE YOU THAT.
BUT NUCLEAR POWER WILL GIVE IT
IN LARGE DOSES AND ACTUALLY
PERHAPS IS THE KEY.
ARE YOU COUNTENANCING THAT?
>> WELL, WE ARE -- WELL, WE ARE
COUNTING ON ALL ALTERNATIVES,
SO, YES, WE HAVE MAPPED ALL THE
ADDITIONAL GAS VOLUMES THAT WE
CAN GET FROM OUR PARTNERS,
STARTING WITH AZERBAIJAN AND
ALGERIA, LNG FROM UNITED STATES,
QATAR, OR EGYPT.
WE ARE ALSO STARTING OUR OWN
BIOMETHANE PRODUCTION.
WE CONSUME NATURAL GAS A LOT,
THIS IS HOUSING.
WE HAVE TO RENOVATE BUILDINGS.
>> OKAY.
COMMISSIONER -- COMMISSIONER, I
WANT TO -- I'M ASKING YOU,
THOUGH, IT SOUNDS LIKE EUROPE IS
TRYING TO MAKE AN OMELET WITHOUT
BREAKING EGGS.
ARE YOU PREPARED TO SAY THAT
NUCLEAR POWER MUST BE PART OF
THE ENERGY SOLUTION?
>> NUCLEAR HAS ALWAYS BEEN PART
OF OUR ENERGY SOLUTION.
EVEN WITH OUR LONG-TERM GOAL TO
BECOME CLIMATE NEUTRAL, WE
ALWAYS HAVE COUNTED THAT
PARTIALLY OUR CONSUBJECTS WILL
BE NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS.
>> AND AS YOU LOOK NOW AT THE
WAY IN WHICH -- LOOK, IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT, THIS.
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE, ISN'T IT?
WHICHEVER WAY EUROPE MOVES ON
THIS IS GOING TO BE DIFFICULT
AND PAINFUL.
WHAT WOULD YOUR MESSAGE BE TO
EUROPEANS TONIGHT?
>> WELL, WE ARE KEEPING A VERY
CLOSE EYE ON THE SUPPLY
SITUATION, AND WE ARE MAKING
SURE OUR CONTINGENCY PLANS ARE
UP TO DATE, BUT ON TOP OF THAT,
OTHER THINGS WE ARE HELPING
UKRAINIANS WHERE WE CAN, AND WE
HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND WE HAVE
VULNERABLE CONSUMERS WHO WE HAVE
TO SUPPORT FROM OUR SIDE.
BUT RIGHT NOW, I THINK THAT THAT
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE CAN DO
HERE IS HELPING UKRAINE.
SO WE ARE PLANNING TO LINK
UKRAINE ELECTRICITY GRID TO THE
EUROPEAN ONE TO KEEP THEIR
SYSTEM STABLE.
THIS IS THE LEAST WE CAN DO FROM
MY FIELD OF RESPONSIBILITY.
AND THEN OF COURSE WE HAVE TO
SEND THEM NECESSARY COMMODITIES.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE DOING.
BUT IN THE MEDIUM TERM WE ARE
PREPARING FOR THE NEXT HEATI